salut à tous bienvenue dans ce nouvel
épisode d'envergure épisode intense on
l'espère on va se plonger un peu plus
dans les coulisses de la draft on
connaît la date officielle évidemment
c'est le 16 octobre pour ceux qui
n'avaient pas suivi et on va essayer
d'en savoir plus sur le processus de
draft et on va aussi prendre des
nouvelles dans des français qui a tendu
dans le top 10 ce soir discussion donc
avec l'agent de killian eyes le français
qui fait donc partie des tops démoc
draft que ce soit aux états unis ou en
france
jan balik ouzou est avec nous bienvenue
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
viennent pour la réalisation et pour
l'interview vous le voyez peut-être pour
ceux qui regardent en vidéo ben est
également ici en direct de montréal
comment ça va ben ça va très bien ouais
ça va très bien aussi ça va très bien tu
sais moi je suis en vacances à la vie
est belle c'est envergure l'épisode 32
de la saison 3 et on est parti
[Musique]
yann d'abord premièrement comment va qui
viennent au niveau de sa santé et ce
qu'il a et ce qui va bien ce qu'il en
pleine forme
est-ce qu'il a aucun soucis de santé il
est aux états unis il me semble bah
écoute oui il va très bien il est aux
états unis depuis le depuis le 13 mars
maintenant et tout se passe bien il
bosse il bosse très bien on a eu la
chance d'avoir une salle privée en fait
et dont il a pu s'entraîner malgré le
confinement en floride et c'était
vraiment une chance et quand je vois
beaucoup de joueurs ont pas eu cette
chance là et ont dû s'entraîner dans des
conditions un peu compliqué nous on n'a
pas trop souffert de ce à quoi bon alors
il va très bien
ibos et comment ça se fait 7 7 salles
privées y avait des connexions il
connaît des gens là-bas ou peut-être que
toi tu connais des gens là bas qui
permettent l'accès à ce genre de salle
il s'entraînait avec d'autres joueurs
tout seul
non non non pas pendant le conflit
aujourd'hui commence à s'entraîner avec
d'autres joueurs en fait comment s'est
passé il faut savoir que tous ses points
forts car tu sais des choses qu'on avait
planifié depuis un an depuis l'été
dernier en fait depuis la fin de l'été
dernier on avait planifié que il
rentrerait quand il rentrerait de sa fin
de saison il ferait une semaine ou deux
à orlando pour rester un peu en famille
et déjà pour faire pas mal de recovery
le travail avec avec un enfin ils
appellent ça un chiropracteur mais c'est
depuis ce kiné ostéo on aimerait ça
comme ça ici ça pas mal de travail de
recovery vu que la saison devait être
longue et ensuite partir à chicago
bosser avec avec will bynum
finalement on a dû adapter un peu le
truc donc il ya eu copie il a dû rentrer
et dont j'ai appelé son entraîneur à
orlando qui disent quand il est là bas
et qui m'a dit qu'il avait accès à des
salles et qui avait pas de problème qui
pouvait s'occuper de lui et donc dès
qu'il est rentré le 13 fois qu'il a pris
juste une semaine pour souffler un petit
peu et ensuite on a commencé à bosser
mais quand on a commencé à bosser
c'était plus du travail de d'entretien
je travail d'entretien et ensuite
essayer un peu de bosser quelques des
aspects qui étaient coincés qu'ils
étaient pointés comme des week-ends chez
lui vraiment voulu se dire bon hockey
ahl corona qui est là mais on va on va
utiliser
période à notre avantage en fait
d'accord et en fait c'est son trailer
qui avait accès à cette salle la quine
salle privée qui appartient pasteur pour
partie d'une école catholique et donc on
a plus on a pu avoir accès à cette salle
c'était super sympa et donc à quoi
ressemble une journée typique en ce
moment de killian dit travailler sur sur
ses faiblesses
qu'est-ce qu'il travaille en particulier
ce qu'on est plus sûr de toujours sur
l'entretien physique et du travail
j'allais dire individuel de
perfectionnement ou est ce que on fait
d'autres choses peut-être renforcement
musculaire sur certains aspects ce genre
de chose depuis lundi dernier
depuis le 22 il travaille et comment sa
journée à 11 heures travail avec un
préparateur physique orienter le travail
sur tout ce qui est au du corps sur un
travail de puissance pas spécialement de
prise de masse ce qu'on veut qu'il garde
sa fluidité et pour tout ce qui est bas
du corps un gros travail d'explosivité
le but c'est de faire de lui un athlète
goal average sur les standards nba en
europe c'est considéré comme un bon
athlète on aime billet il est considéré
comme average
nous ce qu'on voudrait c'est qu'il soit
bob welch donc tout le travail c'est
parfait on a quatre mois dans le travail
de pré draft ça va pas être un travail
pour faire en sorte qu'ils soient bien
pour les work out pour le combat et nous
autres c'est vraiment un travail pour le
préparer à être le plus admiré 10
possibles
là c'est vraiment c'est vraiment ce
qu'on fait on a quatre mois devant lui
donc il travaille justement avec voilà
devant lieu à 11 heures et à 13h et là
c'est training basket et selon les jours
il va commencer à pouvoir faire des pick
up sur orlando ya pas mal de joueurs et
le billet qui vivent à orlando qui sont
sur orlando et il a fait quelques pick
up
que ce soit du wan wan du 2 du 3 3 du
5-5 si possible mais ça m'étonnerait
il a déjà commencé à faire des séances
avec dwayne bacon je crois qu'ils leur
font ils leur faut une ou deux la
semaine prochaine et donc voilà ça c'est
vraiment un truc qui a été décidée il
avait l'occasion de ce pouvoir
s'entraîner aussi avec des des pros qui
sont en europe mais on trouvait pas ça
avec son père en trouvez pas ça
pertinents qui bosse avec des pro
européens
lawrence i dans le sens où on veut
vraiment qu'ils puissent commencer déjà
à s'adapter à la haine billets à pouvoir
ressentir ce que c'est de s'entraîner
avec des joueurs des joueurs nba et sur
la deuxième quinzaine de juillet il va
aller passer une semaine à los angeles
avec will bynum à s'entraîner avec pas
de beverly donc ça ne devrait pas ouais
ouais ça va être pas mal
en fait tu as tu pas de beverly où ils
sont très proches et tous les deux
chicanes oui il nous l'avait dit oui les
voilà papa tu as demandé à wil de
s'occuper de lui quelque temps avant le
départ pour la bubble orlando et oui il
en profite pour rendre les kia n'a vécu
donc ça va être sympa est-ce qui est ce
qu'il y avait c'est la fameuse technique
d'entraînement d'été blanc sur la plage
si tu suis un peu ce que fait qu il yal
il s'entraîne pas mal il fait pas mal de
scènes mark owen a fait pas mal donc à
voir ce serait ça serait intéressant
mais j'avoue que si les frontières sont
ouvertes et que je peux être aux états
unis je paierais cher pour être là et
les voir ce qu'ils vont faire mais un
des aléas de la coved c'est qu'il va y
avoir un gros délais d'ici à l'agrafer
de supposés être cette semaine et elle
va être je crois le 16 octobre
donc en termes de délais comment est-ce
que vous gérez ça ce que vous allez lui
donner une période de repos ou est-ce
que vous allez à toute vitesse jusqu'à
l'adresse ça ça a été le gros challenge
c'est vraiment une question intéressante
donc dès qu'il est arrivé on april a
pris une semaine ou dix jours de repos
vont sa part été du vrai repos complet
parce qu'il a commencé à travailler un
peu physiquement à la maison du conte
savait pas comment ça allait se passer
avec le lock down
ils ont acheté du matériel et immatériel
de muscu pour pouvoir bosser à la maison
derrière quand il a commencé à faire du
tri
il a passé s'est pas entraîné tous les
jours n'a pas commencé par faire cinq
jours s'est entraîné trois fois par
semaine et les deux autres jours il
faisait beaucoup de travail physique à
la maison notamment avec ce 13e ce
matériel de muscu et moi j'étais quand
même en contact avec la une des pieds
pour savoir un peu les tendances et
comment ça allait se passer on savait
que la draft un espace et soit en août
soit en septembre on n'était pas jusqu'à
octobre mais vous ne m'entendez c'était
fin septembre et et on s'est dit bon
voilà une fois qu'on a les vrais date on
commencera vraiment le travail que lui
doivent parce que normalement à
travailler plus d'heures que c'est quoi
pour un joueur qui arrive d'europe c'est
un mois et demi grand maximum ces deux
mois donc on voulait pas non plus le aux
retraites parce que savoir qu'il a fait
deux mois deux mois pleins de travail à
l été dernier il a eu une saison pas
plein mais plein avant le corona on va
dire le faire bosser enchaîner tout de
suite travaillé comme des comme des
acharnés pendant six mois quasiment six
mois de travail et ensuite enchaînées
tout de suite avec sa franchise
ça n'aurait pas été logique physiquement
ce n'était pas logique donc il ya eu
cette période on a pris le temps et là
maintenant depuis lundi là vraiment il
fait cinq séances par jour cinq séances
par semaine deux fois par jour ok
justement tu parles du processus avec
des infos qui tombent petit à petit donc
on rappelle les dates parce qu'on les a
pas encore donné dans notre podcast pour
ceux qui nous ont suivis on les a donnés
avec sur steam sur sur instagram mais
met donc la prochaine la date de la
draft c'est le 16 octobre
et donc quand enfin la règle c'est que
la limite des candidatures ces deux mois
avance comme ça que ça se passe en nba
donc les joueurs ont jusqu'au 17 août
pour poser leur candidature même si la
plupart sont déjà déposés d'ailleurs y'a
ne vous avait pas eu besoin de redéposer
une candidature c'était déjà fait et les
candidats ont jusqu'au 6 octobre donc
dix jours avant la draft pour se retirer
il ya une autre date qui rentrent en jeu
qui concerne pas qu'il ait nails c'est
le 3 août puisque les joueurs qui sont
ici de belley vont devoir décider si il
retourne à la fac ou s'il se déclare
vraiment candidat à la draft c'est la n
6 et qui a qui a mis cette date butoir
on va dire pour une question de bourse
notamment et de place dans les dents les
roster puisque les cours reprennent au
mois d'août ainsi de belley
comment ça va se passer ian des infos
que tu as est-ce qu'il va y avoir des
work-outs dans les franches
6 comme les autres années et ce qui va y
avoir un seul endroit où il y aura des
work-outs des 55 ou ou est ce que vont
se faire les tests médicaux est ce qu'on
en sait un petit peu plus là dessus
la dernière pour l'instant c'est que des
rumeurs
la nba league quelques infos un petit
peu avec la fin travail avec la libye
pillée mellick aussi quelques infos à
gauche cette info lâche
elle n'a pas été encore rester d'ikea
vosges moi je la tiens de la nbi pied
c'est que vraisemblablement le scénario
le plus plausible pour l'instant à
l'heure actuelle ça serait qu'il y ait
peut-être un combat alors leurs dos dans
la bubble en fait mais c'est pas mal
challenging quand même parce que ça
voudrait dire que quid des joueurs
est-ce qu'il faut qu'il soit en
quarantaine avant de rentrer dans la
bubble et qui vont arriver d'un peu
partout
en floride les cas l'écart commence à
augmenter il ya une autre une résurgence
du coc vide
donc voilà c'est le sait c'était la
dernière tendance que j'avais eue mardi
dernier c'est ça m'est donc pas de voir
carte dans les infrastructures des clubs
ça c'est quasiment sûr
a priori non de cette dernière tendance
c'était ça le combat dans la bubble et
potentiellement des pros des avec les
agences des prenait avec les agences
d'accord potentiellement est ce que vous
avez commencé à garder pour en faire un
pot by kilian battant conséquent qu'on
sait pas si s'il pourrait y en avoir il
a pas trop fait maintenant on est sur le
qui vive
moi maintenant je suis ça fait un an que
je travaille avec ail et si une dizaine
de sports & entertainment qui est basée
à l est ils ont une expérience à faire
des projets à aller on a également caché
stanley pour la brafa venir donc s'il
doit y avoir un procès on peut
l'organiser très rapidement est ce que
tu peux rappeler pour ceux qui
connaissent pas ce que ce qu'est un pro
des bains crocs dès l'enfance c'est un
symbole car qui est organisée justement
par une agence ou par les représentants
de joueurs qui trouvent que des équipes
sont invités pour ce côté a parfois un
contre un par point contre 0 le dernier
exemple de prod et qui avait tourné bien
des têtes c'était kristaps posing 10 en
2014 2015 pardon ou est-ce que où est-ce
que par des des équipes dans le top 10
se battait pour avoir une place alors
donc il ya une chose que vous avez eu le
temps de faire pour le moment en tout
cas d'un processus pré draft c'est les
interviews on va parler de ça avec ben
kaka de trois questions là dessus
ouais ce qu'est ce que le processus ait
commencé ah oui depuis un bon moment ça
fait je peux même te dire qu'il a même
un petit peu ralenti sur pendant un mois
quasiment il avait quasiment une par
jour jeune a dû au vendredi alors donc
tous les équipes l'ont contacté pas tout
pas tout beaucoup d' équipe pas toutes
les équipes de la loterie de la loterie
ce qui est intéressant est ce qui ce qui
me fait dire que beaucoup d équipes
réfléchissent à des scénarios a
énormément de scénario c'est qu'il ya
trois équipes qui n'ont pas enfin une
équipe qui n'a aucun choix de draft au
premier tour qui n'a pas arrêté de se
renseigner sur lui qui a fait
l'interview il ya également des équipes
qui ont aucune chance d'être dans la
loterie qu'ils ont énormément scouts et
toute la saison et qu'ils ont et qu'ils
ont faits qui ont été parmi les premiers
à demander des interviews avec lui c'est
une année pour ça hein c'est une année
où est-ce qu'il va y avoir des trails
absolument pas là beaucoup de joie sont
à peu près au même niveau de talent côté
interviews et on commence que ces
structures et une interview avec une
équipe de la nba quelques jours des
questions et demandent combien tu as à
douai ce que je peux nous en dire un peu
plus tard dessus ça dure environ 45
minutes une heure
il ya des questions très basique sûr
la position sur laquelle la position sur
laquelle il se projette en nba
des questions un peu plus intime est ce
qu il a une copine des questions des
questions est ce qu'ils se disent
comment ils se voient une billets est-ce
qu'il achèterait une maison il ya pas
mal de choses comme ça il ya d'autres
équipes
je vais le dire il ya une équipe comme
comme orlando et on a deux d'autres
encore j'ai pu les noix j'ai pu les
équipes en tête qui font des tests qui
font des caisses qui envoie les tests en
landau envoie un ipad avec un test
intégré et s2 cuisse et pas que les
tests de qi des tests de personnalité
d'accord un peu tout ouais nan c'est
assez pointu c'est qu'est ce qu'est ce
qui est ton opinion sur ces tests là
parce que je m'en rappelle
on a été enlevée quelqu'un qui a acquis
qu'ils préparent ces tests là l'année
dernière et nous disait que les agents
étaient pas très chaude tout le talent
toujours à l'idée d'avoir cédé des tests
comme ça qu'est-ce qu'ils ont une
opinion sur les tests de personnalité
nous la chance qu'on a c'est que on a on
a quelques relations donc j'ai réussi à
avoir des questions de tests avant qu'il
passe les interviews donc on a préparé
killian et c'est donc pour un pour un
joueur comme kilian avec sa personnalité
c'est pas trop compliqué les interviews
- comment comment on la prépare et on
l'a fait mockin tordu déjà avec
plusieurs personnes de l'agencé avaient
des rôles différents et on a fait de
bons quines perdu avec les questions
qu'on avait déjà pour préparer pour
qu'il soit à l'aise et moi ce que je lui
ai dit c'est je lui ai dit écoute c'est
pas comme si tu avais une personnalité
un peu borderline
on va dire soit sois toi-même n'y a pas
de bonne ou de mauvaise réponse il va
juste savoir qui tu es donc sois toi
même réponse que tu as à répondre et
ensuite ils feront avec moi sur sa sueur
ça j'avais pas j'avais pas de soucis ce
qui se voit je découpe j'avais pas de
souci tout ça j'aurais peut-être eu plus
de soucis si elle est sortie une
certaine immaturité chez lui l'a
peut-être mon aurait fait beaucoup moins
et qu'on leur ait un peu moins exposée
quoi c'est un peu le jeu de la droite
absolument question que détails sur
lesquels je suis curieux qu'il y en a
vraiment une seule faiblesse apparente
dans son jeu et c'est la main droite
est-ce qu'on lui en a parlé dans les
entrevues sur les feedbacks qui m'a fait
je pense pas qu'on lui en ai parlé non
reparler mais il faut il faut savoir
aussi que avant qu'ils les interviews
moi j'ai parlé à pas mal d'équipés pas
mal de gm et autres en leur disant déjà
je les avais prévenus que qu'iliad était
rentré aux états unis et qui
s'entraînait pour qu'ils sachent qu'ils
s'entraînent et je leur ai dit également
sur quoi on axé le travail
il faut savoir que le travail est aussi
axé sur sa main droite sur nous et pas
tant un travail de ma droite bête et
méchant parce qu'une main droite il en a
une il sait s'en servir c'est juste un
travail pour qu'ils s'habituent et
qu'ils soient à l'aise ouvrit sa main
droite dans les situations il doit
utiliser absolument dans le trafic avec
l'appellation est plus apte de
l'oestrogène et exactement exactement
donc là le travail il ya un gros travail
axé sur sa actuellement il travaille là
entraîneur physique et d'entraîneur
basket sur les traders basque et iona
qui est vraiment sur l'esprit au
développement et à un autre qui est
vraiment spécifique sur des situations
il le met sur des situations de match en
fait sur pas mal de situations de match
et sur toutes ces situations de match là
et noria un gros travail fait sur la
main droite sur trouver les ce qui passe
dans le corner de la malice elle faire
avec sa main gauche dans des finitions
main droite sur des flotteurs ma droite
sur des prises de déprise départ en
dribbles main droite s'il ya pas mal de
choses comme ça sur des prises de pique
ma droite également bon voilà c'est un
travail qui fait depuis depuis deux mois
et demi maintenant il faut qu'elle
dernière question sur les interviews qui
fait les interviews dans les équipes nba
ce qu'elle est les gm sont impliqués
directement à huy sont il ya beaucoup de
gens du personnel ils sont quasiment un
peu moins d'une petite dizaine on va
dire oui oui par équipes une petite
dizaine donc généralement il ya le gm il
peut y avoir le coach je sais que quand
il a fait boston y avait trois stevens
qui pour la petite histoire lui a dit
que qu'il ya de l'été de leurs préférés
de son fils il ya les scouts les
différences coûte directeur de pleurs
personnel
[Musique]
président des opérations basket il en a
eu également
ok ça dépend vraiment des équipes mais
ouais une petite dizaine à peu près un
peu plus ou moins question intérêts
personnels est ce que new york était là
on a fait new york des jeunes est
rassuré je suis content parce que ça
ferait beaucoup de sens côté côté équipe
justement pas par rapport aux
préférences de de kilian est ce que à la
base déjà je n'ai aucune idée mais
est-ce qu'à la base il est fan d'une
équipe en nba et est ce que il ya des
franchises vers lesquels il est plus
attiré en fait puisqu'il ya aussi une
histoire de il ya des stratégies de la
part des équipes il peut y avoir aussi
des stratégies mises en place de la part
des joueurs et agents même si
visiblement vous avez quand même
quasiment accepté toutes les demandes ou
peut-être je sais pas si vous est-ce que
vous avez refusé les demandes déjà on
voit refuser on a refusé des demandes
des équipes où il voulait pas
spécialement à l'est ou peut-être ne
voulais pas spécialement qui lie
d'accord pour quelle raison il voulait
pas y aller parce qu'on n'a pas eu des
retours extraordinaire faut savoir que
dans dans l'idée dans ce qu'on veut
faire avec quillane personnellement
peut-être pas lui mais moi je me fous de
savoir à quelle position il est
sélectionné ce qu'ils m'apportent c'est
la vision à long terme
c'est le système de développement c'est
la manière dont il va être utilisé c'est
ça le plus important
donc qu'ils soient drafté dans le top 10
ce qui serait extraordinaire top 5
encore mieux mais s'il est drafté 16 17
ou 18 et quand on demande une super
bonne situation dans une équipe qui peut
avoir les playoffs et où il ya un bon
système de développement je signe tout
de suite
et donc est ce que l'équipe il a des
préférences aussi j'imagine
est-ce qu'il est fan d'une équipe en
partie pas spécialement il est pas fan
en fait qu'il ya ne s'est pas quelqu'un
qui est fan que ce soit de joueurs ou
autre c'est pas dans sa personnalité
n'est pas spécialement fan d'une équipe
je vous dire un truc qui va sûrement
vous faire sourire mais avant avant lit
on va dire que depuis seulement la
saison dernière on va dire allez depuis
la saison à cholet
il commence à regarder des matchs en
entier regarde et que daylight 2010
concentré il se concentrait sur ces
matches à lui au fond il serait match à
lui sur ce qui faisait son c'était un
plaisir un peu égoïste on va dire que
c'était son basket c'est ce qui faisait
qu'il intéressait ou qui a gardé que des
highlights regardait pas des matchs en
entier c'est on en a pas mal parlé avec
des robes et il a pris plaisir ce match
est en fait je pense même qu'il a
regardée plus de matches d'euroligue que
match nba la saison passée mais on a
regardé c'est quelque chose que je
trouve très sain personnellement comme
traits de caractère de paul thomas se se
voir plus loin qu'il l'ait vraiment se
concentrer sur le moment présent
je crois que c'est vraiment un bon un
bon présage
mais dis moi est ce que en terme de
l'entrevue est ce qu'il y en a qui se
sont particulièrement bien passé ce que
des contacts qui se sont bien est-ce que
le coureur pastry en particulier avec
certaines équipes c'est bon si j'en ai
discuté avec d'autres agents pour
l'instant les franchises ne se déclare
pas vraiment entendre en temps normal
vont sûrement dire oui s'il encore dispo
à telle position
on le draft ou pas que ce soit à l'heure
actuelle généralement les retours sont
d'assez un oui oui on aime bien on aime
beaucoup
vous n'avez pas de promesses de nos
questions s'ils suivent non non on n'a
pas de promesses pour l'instant je sais
qu'il ya des équipes qui l'aiment
beaucoup qu'ils ont beaucoup sujet
pendant la saison une promesse pour
l'instant donc ça veut dire que si on
affirme avec force que kylie anaïs
serein l'autre ific de la prochaine
draft
on peut on peut se tromper bien sûr tout
dépend de la loterie ce que je dis à
tout le monde
trente ans qu'on n'a pas lors de la
loterie on sait que les équipes sont
plus à même de draft et un meneur et
sont sur le marché pour un mineur mais
est un meneur de son type un plus un
playmaker quelqu'un qui est capable
aussi d'amener dans la création
mais quand on n'a pas la loterie c'est
que de la science fiction
s'ils ont des avis très personnel il ya
quand même dans toute la draft ya ni à
un jeu mais un jeu de bluff
qui existent pendant ce processus tant
parlais tout à l'heure il ya des joueurs
qu'on va moins exposé d'autres plus
exposés et c'est par exemple en début de
podcasts je te demandais si la santé
allaient bien est-ce que et est ce que
en gros comment on fait la balance entre
la transparence c'est à dire on donne
les informations aux équipes pour les
rassurer et les certaines petites choses
qu'on cache
je me doute que tu nous a pas caché d un
énorme souci de santé pour pour kilian
mais c'est pas forcément le chose qu'on
des choses qu'on dit en même temps aux
équipes c'est la bonne question mais le
problème c'est que les équipes sont
hyper bien renseignés je peux cacher ce
que je veux à une équipe le trouvera de
toute façon les engagent même des
investigations pour points pour enquêter
sur les joueurs à l'heure actuelle en ce
moment donc je peux essayer de cacher ce
que je veux tout ceci à un moment où on
a entendu parler histoire d'espions à
des nouveaux mieux vaut mieux vaut mieux
être très transparent demain site il y
en a une blessure ou autre je préfère
envoyer le rapport du médecin et les
radios aux différentes franchises en
leur disant voilà ce qui se passe il ya
rien de méchant
il a arrêté pour deux trois semaines
plutôt que de cacher quelque chose bien
sûr des couleurs plus tard c'est
catastrophique
on touche du bois évidemment c'est clair
j'ai marqué salut ma c'est un premier a
draft enfin quinze ans que je me trompe
non pas au quai est ce que comme moi
comment tu t'es tu t'es retrouvé dans
cette position
écoute je veux qu'il ya une depuis qu'il
est très jeune
ce que je me suis sur la fin de carrière
de son père je me suis occupé de son
père ok et quand on a commencé à se
rendre compte que la draft allait être
une réalité pour lui ce pas qu'il était
vraiment à très haut niveau
il a fallu monter le niveau avec lui il
vous faut savoir que moi avant même de
m'occuper de lui j'avais déjà la licence
nba
j'avais pris ma licence nba depuis 2014
parce que je savais que c'est ce que je
voulais faire
sans vouloir manquer de respect à
l'europe au niveau si bas
j'ai tout fait en europe placer des
joueurs en euroligue ou dans des dans
des livres comme l'espagne j'ai tout
fait
et j'appréhende ce métier comme
j'appréhende le basket j'ai joué à un
petit niveau également et donc je peux
être compétitif
moi ce que je voulais c'était atteindre
le plus haut niveau donc la haine
billets ça a toujours été une fin en soi
pour moi ce n'était pas question d'avoir
juste la licence nba pour dire que je
l'aimais que ça fasse beau non c'est
d'avoir pour pouvoir faire du business
en billets à terme donc donc tout ce
qu'il a fallu faire c'est se mettre au
niveau de ce que kia ne faisait être
très proactif et monté les échelons avec
lui il faut savoir aussi que ok c'est ma
première de rap mais avant ça j'ai il a
failli retourner en nba vient même fils
c'est moi qui étais derrière ça il a
fait le training camp et il s'est trouvé
dans une position où il a failli être
pris et et pour la petite histoire la
raison pour laquelle il a été pris dans
le roster au poste ça qu'ils avaient
marc gasol et brendan wright
il se trouve que brenda injury prône sur
le dernier match de pré-saison ya que je
voudrais bien sûr les matches de pré
saison
sur les derniers matches de pré saison
brenda et se blesse et on prend ra la
ligne à la place de yack voilà ce qui
est un terrible choix il faut savoir il
faut savoir qu'au savoir que cette
saison le pire c'est que mon derrière
ici à limoges c'est bien il joue
l'euroligue
mais il faut savoir que sur cette saison
c'est la saison où il ya une hécatombe à
memphis
elle met ou des meubles comme ryan hall
in se retrouve dans le cinq
il ya eu aussi comment il s'appelle j'ai
oublié son nom n'était pas finie dans le
cinq et meilleur marqueur de l'équipe et
je me souviens que memphis camp quand
ils ont coupé ya qui nous ont dit ouais
on aimerait bien garder l'équipe de
geely
mais bon il a une famille et autres et
on avait des offres en europe
mais s'il était resté angeli qui
l'aurait il aurait eu un colloque
immédiatement ouais c'est là mais qu'ils
ont signés je crois genre 20 jours au
moins d'armes et ça c'est exactement ce
que c'est exactement ça c'est cette
saison d'accord est ce que est ce que
dans le processus de pré draft il y
avait des obstacles ou et des embûches
que tu as la peau plus prévoir ce qui
est ce que est ce que ce qui est chose à
vous auquel je m'attendais pas non
la plus grosse en bus ça a été le
courant des virus était le fait de le
savoir que tout ce qu'on a prévu pour un
mois ou un mois et demi doit se passer
sur quatre mois on a été sa l'aspect le
plus le plus gros défi ça a été de
l'avenir nous le dira mais ça a été de
l'entraîner correctement lui mettre le
programme cots règles pour toute cette
durée là c'est bien beau de se dire
qu'ils y aller à fond tout le temps tout
le temps mais est-ce qu'on va pas le
surentraînés est-ce qu'on va peu à peu
près ce risque et une blessure donc ça a
été vraiment de faire la balance entre
tout ça ça a été ça le plus compliqué
maintenant tout est en route
il sent bien on est vachement aller
coûte aussi de lui sachant que c'est un
gros bosseur
voilà on écoute de ski de son corps
aussi mais ça a été ça le plus gros défi
pour moi il n'ya pas là de quelqu'un de
très difficile à moteur et
psychologiquement commun et comment ils
élaborent psychologiquement il aborde
très bien je me souviens quand il est
quand ils sont rentrés en floride
je les appelais quelques jours après je
lui dit bon écoute comment tu te sens
c'est vrai qu'on a de la certitude mais
bon quoi qu'il arrive ça va arriver
et sa réponse ça a été écoute si c'était
arrivé la semaine la saison dernière
j'aurais été inquiet parce que je
n'aurais pas été sûr d'être drafté au
premier tour il dit là aujourd'hui je
suis sûr d'être drafté
donc voilà maintenant tout ce que je
vais faire c'est bosser je sais que je
serai un draft et je vois là je sais pas
j'ai pas de souci mady l'été dernier
aurait peut-être que j'aurais peut-être
un peu stressé sachant que le stress
s'est pas vraiment c'est un de ses
traits de caractère lors et ai été un
peu plus inquiet mais là il est
totalement serein en fait il a vraiment
ils bossent pour en vue de la saison à
venir
banny fait au niveau tu nous a répondu
tout à l'heure avec une réponse en
disant que la franchise dans laquelle il
serait l'important c'est le contexte de
développement une équipe qui lui permet
d'avoir un rôle et c'est néanmoins à
quel niveau
toi et surtout killian vous mettez une
draft réussi est ce qu'il ya un objectif
de la part de qui viennent sur sagna
y a pas spécialement d'objectifs sur ça
c'est clair qu'il aimerait drafté le
plus haut possible lui pour lui il
voudrait draft un trio possible
maintenant honnêtement quand on regarde
les chiffres et le billet ça à paraître
un peu bizarre ce que je vais dire que
ce n'était pas vraiment sur les coûts
travaux qui font de l'argent c'est sur
le deuxième contrat non là bien sûr
important l'important c'est vraiment
pour moi l'important c'est qu'ils
établissent une bonne base sur les
quatre premières saisons
c'est le plus important c'est pas tant
son rookie ciel combien il va toucher
tout de suite c'est pas ça c'est
vraiment qu'il soit dans une situation
puisse établir une bonne base et ensuite
construire à partir de cette base
parce qu'il est vrai qu'on a des
objectifs élevés pour lui dès la saison
prochaine ça c'est une réalité mais les
objectifs élevés sont pas tant sur la
draft à savoir on aimerait qu'il soit
numéro en numéro 5
bien sûr que j'aimerais mais mais s'il
l'est pas c'est pas un drame en soi s'il
tombe dans une bonne situation
le plus important c'est pas la position
de draft le plus important c'est en fin
de saison est ce qu'il est dans un
dessin croquis ça ça peut être un
objectif ça ne l'est ce qui est ce qui
fait le rocking m est ce qu'il est dans
la discussion pourrait troquer
accueillir ça c'est beaucoup plus
important que sa position de draft en
fait c'est vrai une chose sûre je
reviens sur les équipes avec qui il a eu
des entrevues tout à l'heure j'ai oublié
de poser la question si si je te dis
cleveland minnesota golden state est ce
qu il a fait les trois sont les trois
équipes qui ont plus de chances d'avoir
une force physique il n'a pas fait
cleveland
il n'a pas encore fait minnesota mais ça
va se faire il n'a pas encore fait gamin
state et ça va et ça va se faire je peux
dire tout de suite qui frappe à
cleveland pour sur moi je sais pas c'est
pas un secret j'ai parlé avec eux il ya
très peu de chances qu'ils draft un
garde ce qui est logique et de toute
façon conclut gens ne s'intéressent pas
ça intéresse pas un garde sur la draft à
venir ce qui est logique il devrait
faire ok ok très bien eu une dernière
question pour moi peut-être que ben on
aura aussi j'en avais que comment est ce
que tu vas à gérer la tension médiatique
qui va aller croissant
la draft se rapprochant on l'a vu assez
rapidement sur sur bin je sais plus
c'était il ya trois semaines ou quelques
est ce qu'il va être très protégé ou est
ce que ça te gêne pas qu'ils répondent à
des interviews avant généralement les
joueurs qui se présente à la draft eux
ont quand même assez peu d'interviews
dans les médias les derniers mois avant
la sélection déjà vous remarquerez que
qui elle fait très peu d'interviews
cette saison n'a quasiment pas fait
c'est pas c'est pas faute d'avoir eu des
demandes
là on l'a fait parce que c'est un peu
différent mais vous êtes encore un peu
dans le chaos si il ya eu coronavirus il
ya eu la suspension
tous les médias chercher à avoir du
contenu on a été harcelé et et nous dans
l'idée oui on a été harcelé commence et
on s'est dit c'est que il va faire
uniquement des gros médias mais n'en
fera pas souvent injuste envers
quelques-uns comme ça il va il va donner
les discours qu'il a à donner et on
s'arrête là donc il a fallu qu'il a fait
il a une double page dans l'équipe ce
qui était très sympa il a fait bean et
je pense pas qu'on en fera d'autres n'en
fera peut-être proche de la draft mais
encore des gros médias
la cil en refait c'est peut-être plus
des générale des médias généralistes bas
des médias basket où ce sport sera
peut-être plus des médias généralistes
mais maintenant il l'a fait il a fait
quelques médias us il a fais integrated
la fin podcast avec eux il a fait qui
encore might she meets la wii la maison
ça c'était il ya un moment où il était
inégal qui était super intéressant
j'étais dans la pièce quand ils l'ont
fait c'était vraiment super intéressant
de voir comment il voit le jeu et
comment il manipule un peu les
défenseurs et pour ceux en france qui
n'arrive pas à le voir utiliser un bon
bpn voilà comme ça elle comme elle
répond à la critique aussi parce que
mike schmid silence silence quelques
barbe parfois puis j'ai trouvé vraiment
j'aime remettra très stable oui et je
trouvais j'ai trouvé ma chemise c'est
vrai que ça pour pour être très honnête
avec vous c'était une petite inquiétude
on se demandait quand je demandais ce
que mike smith a lui lancé parce que
souvent ils voient là il est lancé et
c'est très bien
il est lent et sur des sur des
faiblesses ça me fait un peu un peu
sourire moi j'aime bien mike on se
connaît ça fait un peu sourire quand il
leur dis à ta place j'aurais fait si
j'aurais fait ça mais on s'attendait à
ce que ce soit un peu plus un peu plus
qu'ils et moi le terme un peu plus solti
mais finalement non je les trouvais
assez assez cool sur ça et qui viennent
très lucide sur ses forces et ses
faiblesses
absolument dernière question peut-être
nous on est des - alex et les gars du
podcast on est des nerd de braves à
l'année longue
jeudi on parle du draft le 26 juin après
que ce soit après ce soit passer
d'habitude mais il ya comme une hype
absolument incroyable qui arrive à
partir du printemps et il ya des modes
grave qui sortent et dont il y en a un
en particulier qui m'intéressait qui est
venu en corner de ringer devait kylie
ann nero 1
est ce que qu'il ya m'accorde quelconque
importance à ces choses qui les lie je
ne lis pas les médias ouais c'est ce que
je pensais même les médias d'information
ou à les médias qui lie pas les médias
et les médias basket en tout cas ils
parlent ils pas les médias basket il
regarde pas ça c'est son père et moi qui
sommes à fond dessus mais qui a ne dit
pas les médias basket on lui parle pas
des modes draft il s'est dit regarde
aller ils regardent peut-être les modes
grave qui espionnent parce que ces
points que lui envoient ses autres potes
joueurs je pense à un particulier qui a
envoyé sa régulièrement pendant la
saison mais sinon
en regarde pas ça ok c'est tout bon pour
toi ben oui numéro un superbe yann merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup d'avoir éclairé
nos landes au coderst jeunesse avec mon
pc à côté mon ipad à droite écoutez vos
podcasts et je trouve ça super
intéressant et ça fait du bien d'avoir
un podcast francophone où des gens ne
disent pas n'importe quoi sur le basket
c'est super intéressant donc longue vie
envergure et continue comme ça les gars
merci beaucoup yann et on souhaite tout
le meilleur évidemment à killian pour la
draft à venir on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler évidemment dans nos podcasts
à bientôt tout le monde on se retrouve
allait très prochainement pour continuer
à disséquer le jeu des différents
prospects pour cette draft 2020 qui aura
donc le 16 octobre
ciao tout le monde